keeping it real real shall we keep it
ready - Oh smell a lot Salam alaikum
greetings of peace
Eddie host of the Deen show we're
keeping a real here I just got done
doing another episode of the Deen show
so I'm excited
it's from Adan coming and we're going to
be coming to you with some great
exciting episodes so make sure you're
tuning in now I wanted to take off with
something that was fresh in my mind I
just interviewed a brother by the name
of Brent recently accepted Islam maybe
four months ago he was in the military
and American and the guy was searching
for the truth for ten years and he was
exposed to Islam to Muslims tried very
hard not to accept meaning that he just
didn't want to believe that Islam was
the truth because it's based on proof
and evidence and the more he was going
into it the more he'd be lying to
himself if he didn't accept it and
that's what many people do they don't
have the courage they see one plus one
equals two where're you gonna go with
that it's only one God worship the
Creator not the creation do what God
wants you to do on his terms not your
desires Islam is straightforward and he
saw past all of the false propaganda and
another unique thing about this
individual and we'll have this solo show
up in Ramadan and so I need you guys to
really tune in to benefit from these
programs that hamdulillah were able to
bring you we also have Yasir Qadhi
coming on and other great shows
especially for Ramadan now what I really
wanted you guys to reflect over that a
is Ramadan so I really need to take
advantage of Ramadan what is it here for
the great wisdom behind it is a law
tells us in the Quran God tells in the
Quran that fasting has been prescribed
for you as it was prescribed to those
before you that you may increase in
taqwa God consciousness that's right so
we can carry you over for the whole year
training the soul to temper to have it
refrain from it writing you you don't
have the wow stallion ride you you ride
it
and many of us are having this Neffs the
desires right us and it's interesting
some was brought to my intentions by a
Muslim and many of us we just away from
the Dean and a lot of times is the
parents fault let me give you just an
example true story and while I'm talking
you're going to see somebody's pictures
so we can be more effective we can
really get the most out of this video
through a visual effect and through the
audio and through the pictures now
listen the brother I hadn't seen him in
years I remember I knew him back from
jaliyah and I ran into him and it was
just real exciting seeing him and he's a
Muslim you know Muslims obviously for
the not yet Muslims turning is one who
chooses consciously to submit to the
Creator not to creation that's what it
is Jesus was Muslim Moses Abraham to all
the prophets were Muslim now you live in
the purpose of life so I saw this
brother and after seeing him under maybe
the four fifth time finally I had
observed some things and I went to his
business and he's got the music jamming
all the time and F bombs coming out of
the mouth and finally I said listen
brother after we talked and I expressed
the love that I had for him and I said
look you know if you don't mind you give
me all this advice
let me share some advice for you plea
you could take it if you'd like and I
think it really benefits you I said look
you know I can tell there's some things
because he expressed being depressed he
expressed having this void in his heart
and I said I'll tell you something
that's really affecting amongst other
things but one of the things you can cut
out immediately and see immediate
gratification is all of this bling-bling
music all of this stuff that's just
getting your desires hot this is audio
pornography is really gonna is really
affecting you cut it out brother even
though you've been addicted to it for so
long
cut it out replace it with the cross and
good lectures some good talks things
that will increase that will charge the
battery charge the heart and then also
these f-bombs the cement look man you a
Muslim cognizant that look Allah is your
Lord your Creator the Creator who
created you look he don't like these
profanities coming out of our mouths the
tongue that remembers the Creator it
should not utter these things so at
least when you're around me try not to
tell it all this foul language come out
of your mouth and maybe you'll start to
be more cognizant of that and then you
probably replace it
now they come out with anybody but he
said you know what and going back to
linking it back to the parents mean to
blame he said man I've been swearing my
whole life my father there was a curse
seeing my brother's curse everyone's
cursing I said subhanAllah you see
parents what examples have you been to
your kids so now the kid is just
mimicking mom and dad dad smoke in right
letting f-bombs out what do the kids do
doing the same same thing so it's time
to make a change so I said let you be
the one who makes a difference now you
can make the change and children are
rising up now and helping their parents
see the way that's pleasing to the
Creator Islam so you study it you learn
it you implement it and you be the role
model for your parents not in parents
now is Ramadan let us get with it all of
us to really reflect and think deaf can
come at any time and then tomorrow
bye-bye is too late what do we leave
behind if not a righteous child another
thing that I was I wanted to share with
you from this story that I did with
Brent who's coming up and Roemer down
his story was he lost his son he lost
his son two month old baby boy you know
how hard that is
subhanAllah he's going through many
challenges and tests and for those now
who think I'm just gonna come into this
Deen this way of life and think it's oh
yes hallelujah it's all good no Allah
says in the Quran look the crater's
saying AHA see Banias ain't rappin yaku
no amman now a homely you've done old do
you think that you just say I believe
and you won't be tested this life is a
test but I want in everyone's being
tested but some have the Creator with
them and some don't
and Allah is saying with every
difficulty finding a malice through
straw in the mallow still straw with
every difficulty comes the relief the
ease twice he says it so be expecting
it's coming so I don't think now okay
you just take the Shahada
yeah hey Lala there's nothing worthy of
worship so the creator of heavens inner
muhammad is his messenger including that
excluding Jesus Moses and all the
preceding messages we know how it goes
and now
we think it just all smooth and dandy no
is going to be trials and tests Allah is
testing your sincerity and I always
refer people to the show I did with dr.
Lawrence Brown who he lost when he
accepted Islam he lost his he's a
successful doctor lost his house his
guesthouse and his dog his wife took it
all and he was sleeping in the pay by
day motel and he testifies that he held
on I was test Allah was testing him and
at the end what happened he got twice
full three times full back new family
new well everything Allah because that's
not lost promised the crater's promise
what you leave what you lose in the path
of Allah will replace it so hold
steadfast to those who are Muslim
thinking about being Muslim you will be
challenged but there are no group of
people who are on who were not on the
truth look at Jesus he was spit on he
was ridiculed they tried to kill him all
the messengers what happened they were
what trying to win a popularity contest
just blending in no they were speaking
the truth and what happened at the end
they were victorious
they got Jenna paradise waiting for them
that's what you have waiting for you but
we have to stay steadfast and with the
last thing I want to end is I heard also
is brought to my attention it was a
Muslim making a claim or saying and many
of us again out of ignorance we don't
know the Dean we don't know the purpose
so he said I dare anyone to find me
anything better dinner
riding through LA with the dog on my lap
and listening to Tupac doing like this
dis dis stuff I mean really when you do
have like the law when you have this
Dean in your heart you've connected the
heart back to the maker of the heart
that is when you have this contentment
this peace you know you go to the gym
and you you chase this feeling that you
get from they call it a runner's high
but we when we've experienced based on
proven evidence not blind faith no Islam
is based on clear evidences and proofs
that is indeed from the maker the
creator of mankind definitely without a
doubt and now you experience this this
this feeling and then you end up chasing
in your whole life because it's not
everyday now you're on a cloud floating
high no like everyone else sometimes you
come to the prey it's luggage sometimes
you're in it all the way half percent
some people have their prayer accepted
twenty thirty forty percent as is stated
in a hadith depending on your
concentration your sincerity many people
don't understand the Quran the language
that's why it's a lifetime journey of
learning understanding and chasing what
you've experienced because many of us
would come into this D and then Allah
lets us taste the sweetness of Iman and
then it drifts off and then again we
chasing it it comes and goes you know
what I'm saying but what are you chasing
on the other side this is something that
brings our vibrant stew the heart
rejuvenates the heart subhanAllah and at
the end you have Jenna guarantee for all
the struggles that you go through
because as the last and final messenger
said the mankind the problem and peace
be upon me said there is no affliction
that befalls a believer except it's good
for him
not even the prick of a thorn that
expiates your sins and many how many of
us are not making mistakes
each and every day subhanAllah so what
good comes to you you're at hamdulillah
thank God a calamity comes you're
patient and there's goodness in that and
at the end Jenna is waiting for you
Jenna that's it so let us take advantage
of this blessed month of Ramadan aslam
based on the five pillars testify that
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the creator of the heavens and earth and
Mohammed is a last and final messenger
Jesus fasted we accept him as a message
not a God he never claimed to be God a
son of God and He died for people's sins
people go away from religion because of
all this man-made hocus-pocus mum-mum
mumbo jumbo that doesn't make sense but
we believe in a believable message based
on a believable book the Quran testable
a living miracle and all of the
guidelines are there so after we
established this the salat five times a
day we have to be connecting with our
minimum connecting the heart back to its
maker giving to the poor
does a cat hedge once in your lifetime
and now you have the blessed month of
ramadhan it's here don't lose it
take event whatever you've done in the
past give it up now and inshallah you
can leave off all of those vices for
this month train yourself control
yourself
discipline yourself and make what is
good for you a way of life this Deen is
good for your heart it's good for you in
this life and in the hereafter because
we're going to die and at the end it's
only two places Jenna or Jahannam that's
it so we love the best for everyone
keeping it real here really reflect
what's the purpose of life why you've
been created and Muslims you know and
the not-yet Muslims really investigate
Islam keep watching the Deen show and
those who've been slacking off get with
it get with it because we know anyone
who testifies and believes in LA ilaha
illa llah mohammad rasool allah will be
in jena but some will have to spend some
time to go ahead and expiate for the
wrongs the evils the sins that people
have done in Jahannam we don't want to
spend a second there so now is the time
to be cognizant court my purposes and
Ramadan is this blessed month don't lose
out on all the wonderful rewards and
make sure also that you're sharing share
this share this with your friends and
family tell people about the DS Show
subscribe if you haven't already right
now do it like us on the Facebook now
we're on the Instagram we're using all
these social media tools I'm telling you
if you're not using for good man this
stuff really effects too hard to use it
for the good there's all sorts of all
sorts it's just I don't want to get into
it things that are out there but use it
for the good that it can be used for so
go ahead and share this Twitter Facebook
like our shows follow us you know how to
rest goes and I'll see you next time
thank you very much Salaam alaikum peace
be with you